[ethereal music]
Menon: WeVideo was founded
with the vision
of making digital storytelling
and video creation accessible
to anyone, anywhere.
When we first started on
the Android, we clearly saw
that there wasn't a compelling
application
for a video creation.
Combine that with the fast
growth of Android platforms--
we decided to go Android first.
Since then, the majority
of our investment
in smartphone development
has been on Android.
What separates us from other
applications on Android
is that we give you the full
capability of the device
in our application.
You're able to take
different clips, trim them,
and we were able to do that
because the Android platform
gave us access
to the OpenGL air,
which allowed us to do
real-time rendering
and previewing.
Since the launch
of our new application,
mobile monetization has done
very well for us.
The revenue on Android has
doubled every two months.
Almost 85% of our users
are on Android.
When we launched
the material design,
we decided to redo
the application
and redo the user experience
and take it up
to the next level.
Tsaregorodtsev: Many of
the material design concepts
really resonated with us.
We were really able to create
a delightful experience
for our users.
And as a result,
we saw 100% increase
in user engagement.
Being able to reply to reviews
is a great feature.
Every day, we go through
every single review
and analyze the data
that's coming in.
And most importantly,
if there is somebody
who's having a problem,
we can help right away.
And it's such a great feeling
when you can see someone
who gave you one-star reviews
converting them
to four or five stars.
We love running experiments
on the Play Store.
For example,
just recently,
we updated our screenshots
with the colors, the text,
and we saw increase
in conversion
up to 50%.
Making the app available
in different languages
is critical to you to succeed
in global marketing.
We saw increase in our installs
up to 200% in regions
have utilized our app
and the Play Store
subscriptions.
Recently, we revisit
our purchasing flow in the app.
We wanted to see
if we can convert more people
to buy our premium products.
We decided to change colors
of the background,
font size
of all of the elements.
We were able to deploy quickly
and the trade just
was in a few days.
And we saw the increase
up to 60%
in conversion rate.
Menon: The Android platform has
been a great platform
for us to get
a regular application.
With a fast app publishing
process,
Play Store listing experiments,
feedback from users,
and monetization
using Google Wallet,
this has led to a tremendous
increase in success
with installs and revenue.